[Music]
hello everyone my name is Pete also
known as Snell them I'm here to talk to
you about this game that we've reviewed
called elements space now when you take
a look at this game
you are going to look at it as a
dialogue type tactical game now it's a
little mesh is a whole bunch of
different types of elements in it now
the elements that you look at is the old
types of XCOM games and also it adds
that new aspect just like a starcraft
where you can move your characters
throughout your screen with the instant
combat of a mutant Year Zero now I found
that the combat itself in it was was a
little little wonky a little controls
are a little hard to play and deal with
now normally you would know a lot easier
who your character was patrolling and
when you're watching this video you'll
even see me run through a bunch of Mines
and get one of my people killed because
I thought a different person was picked
now it was kind of hard to see that now
just to take a step back the game itself
is about you as the captain of this ship
that is housing a a Galactic Senate
meeting if you will now you have three
weeks to to to fix this meeting because
it is being overthrown and and you are
being attacked now your sense because an
infiltrator is going into the ship
this infiltrator then ends up figuring
out you know that you are on on their
heels and retaliates now once they
retaliate you end up going after him and
then you are flagged as the enemy and
you have to flee the ship and then you
are sent to another location which is
another part of the Senate which you'd
think they'd all be talking to each
other but apparently they don't and you
then go and you're there to help them
now there's a lot of different things in
the game which I thought was cool you
have reputations you have skill points
you have what looks to be about six or
seven characters that you can control
three max during each mission so those
aspects were pretty cool the graphics on
them are scaled back what I'm use to is
XCOM floor graphics now they have put a
lot of work and a lot of effort into it
and the graphics themselves are great
and x-column games now this is probably
a couple of notches down because it
looks like this game is just learning
what they're doing and the graphics
aren't that bad what I really like is
the kill moves you have kill shots which
if you're shooting them with a gun
you'll see them with a slow-mo and the
kill or you have a melee class character
which is something I've never seen in a
tactical game like this which makes that
character a lot more difficult to play
and it's new now as for the other people
to the standard run-of-the-mill
characters shoot heal things like that
and it's pretty cool now what what I
think is neat about this is a lot of
those missions you get ask questions in
between them and those missions
apparently
changed the outcome of the game now I'm
gonna try to run through this game to
see how the whole thing plays out and
then I'm not trying to run it again to
see if anything changes
for instance different characters you
might get because you have the option of
going to find this kid that is lost or
you end up having to follow this serum
on the ground which one you pick so I
ended up following the serum not saving
the kid which is very unlike Maine
because I was trying he'll be help
people and save everybody but it was
it's kind of interesting and there
there's what seems to be the skill trees
but they I'm not exactly how far they
work because I haven't gotten them tough
point yet we're going to plug I said
we're going to play it a little more and
hopefully we'll do another little update
like I said the patrols are wonky
graphics are kind of kind of good but
not too bad kills are kind of cool the
cutscenes if you will the right dialogue
seems pretty good there's no voice
acting but there is the regular dialogue
on the screen like you would have
thought and the quote-unquote olden days
and in in those old Zelda type games you
have to read and kind of think of what
the voices might be which I liked so
it's it's not that bad I wouldn't say
that it's a great game I would say you
know if it's on sale pick it up it looks
like it's got a lot of content in it and
I'm gonna exactly continue to go along
with this and we'll see how it goes and
the factions how they play I'm not sure
so I want to see how those in a plane
also
so now thank you very much for listening
to the review being that this is for the
era modes podcast I would like to tell
you all to make sure that you check them
out there Sundays eleven o'clock during
the football season and then at
one o'clock during the non football
season which they are on break now they
will be back in January so go ahead and
take a look at that and like I said if
you get some time go ahead and take a
look at elements space and you'll you'll
see it you'll enjoy it so uh thanks for
watching see you there thank you right
robots
orbit of Venus
position plots or backgrounds
background information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in three weeks time that ship we just
saved masterpiece
[Music]
terminal Oh
[Music]
tells you reached and maybe points this
is your main character
rattling hook
Zero's
choose
[Music]
this spot
students
cleanser
she's
[Music]
ah
Oh
[Music]
knowing
well
[Music]
she's a beast
[Music]
hmm
I'm sorry that's gonna blow up
[Music]
blind abusers
Oh
that was by proxy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there
Oh God
[Music]
II
[Music]
[Music]
Spur eat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I only knew
[Music]
watch
it
[Music]
[Music]
it's nice
all just 60 damage to push them into
something
[Music]
this members on
[Music]
meet her live
[Music]
[Music]
that's some crazy [ __ ] going on out
there
[Music]
could kill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nearly locked
boom
[Music]
this is all terrible decision
[Music]
[Music]
oh the Jesus
[Music]
No oh my god I was the one character oh
dear not positive for the home coach I
how about ends Annalise can be revived
by clicking on them or using healing
skills over those will be wounded for a
few turns closing in two points to the
client will come it ends fallen islands
will fall on allies recover but are
wounded when the next combo begins of
wounded allies son of a [ __ ]
I am pissed right now to no end
[Music]
I would love to redo the last shoe mats
I'm so pissed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have to put this better
[Music]
[Music]
that was pretty graphic
[Music]
bugs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cover
[Music]
[Music]
you there
[Music]
you
[Music]